撮影場所上だったんですけど下に変えました
俺が気づいてしまったんだなぜ俺は生活と撮影の場所を分けてしまったんだ
そういう中バーチャルもの生活と動画撮影は切っても切れませんから
ユーチューバードルもの生活と動画撮影は切っても切り離せないものなんです
なんであの名馬を完全に女良の部屋ですベッドタートとポテトチップス4回も置いて
ないです
でしたはもう撮影と生活ととは先生動作 z 生活は切り離しちゃダメなんですよ
そうやっぱこの生活感あふれる感じを俺がね伝えたい
ん
髪の毛切りましたよって夕日はん
人はんっ台風せいでちょっと気分が悪い君よこちらですパパん
ぼっこぼこやんって自分で作るスーパーボウルでございます
いろんなことができますねあの質問をコーナーとか文房具障害とかも徐々にしていこう
と思いますがちょっとね最近バタついててあとアニメの見すぎでこれほんとはね俺ね
まぁ2つ買いました
本当はこれ俺100個ぐらい買ってまとめて最強のバカでかい自分で作るスーパー
ボールを作ろうと思うんですけども多い
てに2つしたかったのとインターネットで買おうと思っても何かねもうねやっくん
肌が中心に言ってるんですよあまぞを手に入ることが不可能みたいな色がちょっと見る
のじゃないですね
悔しいんですけどもば様にはこう庶民的にね普通に遊ぼうと思いますってシールが入っ
てる業界シェルが入ってるじゃん
結構固いな割とはにとか堪えそうでやはりとはスーパーボウルだからな
スライブではないんだけどスライムボイスでも取れたまたはあっさり取れました
[音楽]
ん
パワー実はこれほんとはねまじ100個作ってやりたかったよ
要するにこれは108て組み合わせれば職場でできますからね
割と版てるなうんっ
俺とさせる
ワークってこんな殺傷能力考えですね
じゅ丸くしなきゃこれだけばなかった ze な事務所を
[音楽]
大菅とりあえずなんだろどんな形にでもなるスーパーコール的な感じかな
変幻自在だは薄暗いですこれは多分スーパーボウルとしてちゃんと動くはずです
いやっほげっ日常的で使ってる部屋のほうがやっぱ取り水で動画はこの1つはじゃあ
合わせてみましょう
意外とギター色同士だから何工房大きな変化がないかな
割と姉は割とちょっとおしゃれな色になって今日します
俺これちょっと保存しとこで何かこういうタイプのチューバボールちょっと見つけた
限り買ってちょっと頑張って100個
集めて za 実が作ります芳町のある方です
町丸井です
おおすごい全然跳ねるじゃあこれたぶんあれだよ
資格自覚したら近くしたらどこに飛ぶかわかんないみたいな新たな音遊びができる
許氏まで見て蛍四角いスーパーオールなんて俺はないね
面白いボールじゃないけどボールじゃないけど失格椅子ば打掛るッスば資格っていう
よしこれはだけれどどこに飛ぶかわかりませんからね
[音楽]
うわーんホラー
ん
どっ
ザーッほらっ子
割と走りあげ
ヴァンティアン前これ選択これはまあ台風時にコーラ飛ばして進んでいくものの服が
汚れるっつったらどういったこのあとこれを選択すればいいんだ